جاريد كوشنر مرحبًا بك في البرنامج ،
شكرًا لك ، من الجيد أن أكون معك ، لذا
انظر إلى 24 ساعة بعد الإعلان
عن
اتفاق السلام التاريخي هذا بين إسرائيل وأم
والإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
أريد فقط أن أسأل بالتحديد ما
الذي تعرفه بالضبط
فعلت إدارتك  أعني أنك تعلم بوضوح أفضل
مما أفعله أن هذا كان قيد
العمل
منذ 10 سنوات على الأقل بين
الأطراف
وأنت تعلم بمساعدة
إداراتنا السابقة ،
هل يمكنك إخبارنا كيف ولماذا حدث
الآن الأول  الشيء الذي فعله الرئيس ترامب هو
أنه ذهب إلى الرياض في عام 2017
حيث جمع قادة 54
دولة إسلامية وقال يا رفاق إننا بحاجة
إلى التفكير في الأمور بشكل مختلف
نحتاج إلى حل هذه المشكلات
معًا ونحتاج إلى
توحيد المنطقة حول
حلول مشتركة  وبطريقة جديدة
أه منذ ذلك الحين رأينا الكثير من
التغييرات التي رأيناها تقترب إسرائيل
من الدول العربية لقد
دحرنا الكثير من عدوان إيران في  أنهت المنطقة
الصفقة الإيرانية المعيبة حقًا أه
استعدنا الخلافة المالية
لداعش وقمنا بالكثير من العمل لمكافحة
تمويل الإرهاب وخوض
معركة طويلة الأمد
ضد التطرف من خلال
مراكز مكافحة التطرف من خلال
خوض المعركة
عبر الإنترنت ، لذلك أعتقد أن الرئيس ترامب
كان قادرًا على إعادة الثقة مع
جميع الحلفاء الإقليميين الذين كانت لديهم أمريكا
ووضع استراتيجية ، ثم
عملنا معًا بشكل وثيق للغاية على مدار
السنوات الماضية لتنفيذ تلك الاستراتيجية
وبلغت ذروتها في  اتفاقية السلام الأولى
في المنطقة في آخر 26 عامًا ، لذا
مرة أخرى ، هناك الكثير من المشاكل
التي واجهتنا في الشرق الأوسط بمرور الوقت ،
لكن
قلة قليلة من السياسيين والقادة
تمكنوا من تحقيق الاختراق
الذي تمكن الرئيس ترامب من تحقيقه
بالأمس
من الواضح أن هذا تقدم في
المنطقة
وتحديداً في قضية
تحدثت عنها
أنت وأنا عندما كشفت عن خطة الإدارة الرابحة
للسلام في المنطقة التي تتذكرها.  كان أحد
الأسئلة الأولى التي طرحتها عليك هو هل سيقوم
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو بضم
الضفة الغربية كما هو منصوص
عليه وقلت لأنه قال ذلك
وقلت لا لا ، لا
نتوقع أن هذا لا ينبغي.
حدث ليس سراً أنك لم ترغب في
أن يحدث ذلك
هو أحد الفوائد الجانبية أو المنفعة
الجانبية لهذه الصفقة الإعلان عن تعليق إسرائيل لهذا
الضم ،
وبالتالي فإن السياسة فوضوية وفي الشرق الأوسط
إذا كان هناك حل أنيق.
لحل كل هذه المشاكل ، كان من الممكن
حلها منذ وقت طويل ، وبالتالي
لديك الكثير من الأحزاب المختلفة التي
تؤمن بالكثير من الأشياء المختلفة ، ولكن
ما حدث هنا في النهاية هو أن
القادة اجتمعوا مع قادة عظماء مثل
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ولي
العهد  محمد بن زايد والرئيس
ترامب واستطاعوا أن يضعوا ما هي
مصالح شعوب
المنطقة والعالم في
المقدمة أه مختلفة ربما أشياء
كان من الممكن أن تكون جيدة باختصار.  على المدى
ولكن أقل فائدة على المدى الطويل
، ولهذا السبب نحن قادرون على الوصول إلى
هذا التطبيع والسلام الذي
سيسهل التجارة العظيمة
بين الإمارات العربية المتحدة وإسرائيل التي
ستسهل التبادلات في
سياحة الرعاية الصحية التكنولوجية الكثير من المسلمين في
جميع أنحاء  لا يعتقد العالم
أنهم قادرون على زيارة المسجد الأقصى
لأن بلادهم
ليس لديها علاقات دبلوماسية
ولا يمكنهم السفر إلى تل أبيب ثم الذهاب
لزيارة المسجد
الآن يمكن للمسلمين في جميع
أنحاء العالم الطيران  من خلال دبي وأبو
ظبي ،
انتقل إلى تل أبيب ويمكنهم الصلاة في
المسجد وهذا سيساعد في
محاربة فكرة أن
المتطرفين يقولون إنه
لا يُسمح للناس بالصلاة في
المسجد وأن المسجد يتعرض
للهجوم و  هذا عبارة عن
مجاز تم استخدامه لما تعرفه
منذ أكثر من 100 عام